[Música]
donald trump anunció que dio positivo
para kobe de 19 también está contagiada
de la primera dama de eeuu melania trump
y ambos están en aislamiento en la casa
blanca se hicieron la prueba después de
que este jueves ojo hicks una de las
asesoras más cercanas del mandatario
diera positivo tras presentar síntomas
en medio de la recta final de la campaña
presidencial
el presidente francés emmanuel macro no
presentó de este viernes su plan de
acción contra el separatismo
principalmente del islamismo radical la
llamada ley anti separatismo busca
proteger la república y los valores
franceses pero es criticada por muchos
religiosos como un discurso anti
musulmán tenemos informes desde parís
y con seis votos a favor y cinco en
contra la corte de suprema de justicia
de méxico declaró constitucional la
consulta popular propuesta por el
presidente andrés manuel lópez obrador
según la cual la ciudadanía debe decidir
si cinco ex presidentes del país hermana
juicio por corrupción
una feliz mañana de viernes aquí
comienzan las noticias de france 24 mi
nombre es ángela gómez iniciamos el
informativo en eeuu el presidente de
donald trump informó que dio positivo
para kobe 19 en un tuit publicado cerca
de la medianoche del jueves el
mandatario dijo que él y la primera dama
melania trump estaban contagiados la
noticia llega pocas semanas antes de las
elecciones presidenciales y en medio de
duras críticas sobre como trump ha
manejado la crisis aquí la historia
esto es facturado en un tuit lo anuncio
donald trump dijo esta noche la primera
dama y yo hemos dado positivos en el
test de kobe 19 comenzaremos nuestro
proceso de cuarentena y recuperación
inmediatamente pasaremos esto juntos la
noticia llega después de que job ix una
de las asesoras más cercanas al
presidente reveló síntomas y dio
positivo de coronavirus ella viajó con
el presidente varias veces esta semana a
bordo del air force one y fue vista
cerca de otros funcionarios de la
campaña durante un mitin en pensilvania
el sábado sin llevar mascarilla en un
comunicado de la casa blanca el médico
personal de trump sound conley dijo el
presidente y la primera dama están bien
en este momento y planean permanecer en
la casa blanca durante su convalecencia
espero que el presidente continúe
cumpliendo con sus deberes sin
interrupciones mientras se recupera
después de conocer sus resultados
positivos el presidente trump dijo que
él y la primera dama se aislarían pero
no dijo por cuánto tiempo la primera
dama dijo en twitter que ella y el
presidente se sentían bien y que ella
había aplazado sus próximos compromisos
el vice presidente mike pence dijo que
rezaba por la rápida recuperación de la
primera pareja su mba menospreciado
constantemente la gravedad de la crisis
sanitaria que ha matado a más de 200.000
estadounidenses hasta ahora a los 74
años y con sobrepeso trump está en un
grupo vulnerable para los que contraen
el virus la noticia ha lanzado una nueva
incertidumbre en la recta final que
conduce a la elección presidencial con
mítines y debates previstos en los
próximos días y semanas y es que a
donald trump ha desestimado
constantemente los peligros del nuevo
coronavirus incluso recientemente llegó
a admitir que intentó restarle
importancia al virus para no provocar
pánico entre el pueblo americano luego
de que se revelara una entrevista
concedida por él en marzo --momento para
ver un recuento de los comentarios del
líder republicano desde el inicio de
esta panda
en febrero tran dijo que el coach 19
podría desaparecer milagrosamente en
abril
este es sólo uno de los comentarios que
donald trump ha hecho desde el comienzo
del brote de coronavirus para descartar
la gravedad de la situación
hemos hecho un trabajo increíble vamos a
continuar va a desaparecer algún día
como un milagro
gerardo the world sp hérner a pesar de
las pocas pruebas de su eficacia trump
ha elogiado abiertamente la hidroxi
cloroquina como una forma de evitar el
kobe 19 una droga antimalaria que él
mismo ha dicho haber tomado en abril
pareció sugerir otros tratamientos no
verificados y dañinos como inyectarse
desinfectante
aunque tran dijo más tarde que los
comentarios eran irónicos
supongamos que impactamos el cuerpo con
una tremenda luz ultravioleta o sólo una
luz muy poderosa y luego veo el
desinfectante que lo elimina en un
minuto un minuto hay alguna manera de
que podamos hacer algo así por medio de
una inyección en el interior o una
limpieza a medida que los casos
comenzaron a aumentar y que varias
partes de estado
sonidos fueron confinadas los expertos
en salud subrayaron la importancia del
distanciamiento social y el uso de
máscaras prácticas subestimadas en gran
medida durante los mítines de la campaña
trump como en este de junio
el propio presidente rara vez fue visto
con una máscara sólo en julio fue visto
por primera vez usando una en público ya
me había puesto una antes me la puse en
esta zona de atrás pero no quería dar a
la prensa el placer de ver leerse según
trump de eeuu ha pasado lo peor de la
pandemia que ha matado a más de 200.000
estadounidenses sin embargo sus propios
expertos en salud han dado a menudo
evaluaciones menos positivas de la
situación del país
entre tanto pedrosa dan un quiebre y eso
es director de la organización mundial
de la salud también publicó en la red
social twitter un mensaje para desear
pronta recuperación de donald trump y su
esposa melania el líder del organismo no
ha tenido la mejor relación con el
presidente que ha criticado el manejo de
la enfermedad por parte de la o ms y que
busca retirar el apoyo de su país
también habló del primer ministro
británico boris johnson
mis mejores deseos al presidente donald
trump y melania trump para una
recuperación completa y rápida mis
mejores deseos para el presidente de
trump y la primera dama espero que ambos
se recuperen rápidamente del coronavirus
deseando a mi amigo donald trump y
melania trump una rápida recuperación y
buena salud
si su estado de salud empeora trump
tendría que ceder su lugar al menos
temporalmente al vice-presidente mike
pence esto ya sucedió dos veces en el
pasado según la sección 13 de la
vigésimo quinta enmienda de la
constitución de eeuu adoptada en el 67
tras el asesinato del presidente john f
kennedy en 1963 trompo podría declarar
por escrito su incapacidad para cumplir
con sus deberes pero el momento no es el
mejor para incapacitar se a 33 días de
las elecciones y cuando siguen en el
aire las críticas contra el primer
debate que lo enfrentó el demócrata joe
biden
en un viaje por tren en el medio oeste
un territorio tradicionalmente a favor
de los republicanos el candidato
presidencial por el partido demócrata
joe bayrén calificó como un accidente de
tren en el debate del 29 de septiembre
alcanzó
en cierto momento pensé y tal vez no
debería decir esto pero el hecho de que
el presidente de eeuu se condujera de la
manera en que lo hizo fue una vergüenza
nacional
nachum bears muchos votantes coinciden
con el candidato en el debate trump
interrumpió al moderador y a su rival
unas 71 veces mientras que bardem
solamente lo hizo en 19 ocasiones esto
llevó a la comisión de debates a
anunciar cambios en el formato para los
próximos eventos algo que no agradó a
trump quien respondió con un mensaje en
la red social 'twitter' porque
permitiría que la comisión de debates
cambiará las reglas para el segundo y
tercer debate cuando la última vez gane
fácilmente
además de su comportamiento durante el
debate trump ha sido criticado por su
negativa a condenar la supremacía blanca
la noche del debate vivo en lo que me
mantiene despierta por la noche ver a un
residente de eeuu en un debate con el
presidente potencial negarse a condenar
a los supremacistas blancos negarse a
comprometerse con una transferencia
pacífica del poder
registro pistol transfer parlament pero
trump necesitó casi 48 horas para
condenar de manera clara a los
supremacistas blancos durante una
entrevista a los dos candidatos de que
da un poco más de un mes para seducir a
los pocos votantes indecisos cambiamos
de tema el presidente francés emmanuel
macrón presentó la llamada ley anti
separatismo en la que prevalecen los
valores seculares y republicanos de
francia por encima de los valores
religiosos el proyecto ha sido rechazado
por algunos sectores que lo califican de
anti musulmán y es que llega a siete
meses después de que el gobierno
anunciara que combatiría la inter
extranjera en la práctica del islam
dando fin a un programa que permitía a
los países enviar imanes y maestros a
francia
lo que tenemos que abordar es el
separatismo y la amistad separatismo
islamista que tampoco gustó un proyecto
político religioso consciente teorizado
político o liu que se concreta a través
de repetidas desviaciones de los valores
de la república drive y bridge que a
menudo resultan en la constitución de
una contra sociedad
los detalles de esta legislación los
tiene en parís nuestra periodista
natalia ruiz
natalia buen día para usted cuál fue el
mensaje de emanuel macrón
sí muy buenos días pues marco lo hizo
desde el embrujo que es un suburbio a 35
km de parís y que es ejemplo de los
problemas que se viven en este tipo de
lugares el durante una hora pues se dijo
que esta estrategia pues no busca crear
amalgamas pero hay que hablar de sin
tapujos de ellis la más radical en el
país una estrategia que él dividió en
cinco puntos por una parte la
neutralidad de los servicios públicos un
mayor control de las asociaciones a ver
cómo se financian qué tipo de acciones
realizan hablo muy importante de la
educación dijo que a partir de 2021 la
educación la instrucción será
obligatoria a partir de los 3 años y que
también pues las escuelas que no están
bajo contrato con el estado serán
sometidas a un arduo control para saber
qué tipo de programas están
implementando y también que quienes son
los pedagogos detrás de todo esto hijo
es una parte que el islám debe ir de la
mano de la república y por esto como
ustedes lo decía pues no podrán venir ya
y mums
aquí a francia desde el extranjero sino
que son los imanes en francia serán
formados aquí mismo en el país también
pues habrá mayor control también de
saber quiénes están detrás de las mesas
como se financian las acciones que están
realizando y para esto pues él también
quiere que haya una mayor inversión en
la educación superior todo esto pues
será presentado en un proyecto de ley a
comienzos de diciembre gracias natalia
la suprema corte de méxico dio los verde
a la consulta popular para decidir si se
enjuicia a cinco ex presidentes del país
aunque la iniciativa impulsada por el
mandatario andrés manuel lópez obrador
no mantuvo su pregunta original que
incluía los nombres de carlos salinas
ernesto zedillo vicente fox felipe
calderón y enrique peña nieto- el
informe de alan austria
5 expresidentes de méxico serán
sometidos a consulta popular para
decidir si son enjuiciados así lo
determinó la suprema corte de justicia
tras un acalorado debate y con una
votación dividida el máximo organismo
judicial declaró constitucional la
iniciativa impulsada por el presidente
andrés manuel lópez obrador con la que
se busca que los mexicanos decidan si
llevan a juicio a ex mandatarios así
como otros altos funcionarios de
gobiernos anteriores por posibles
delitos cometidos estuvimos planteando
distintas alternativas y hemos llegado
ya a una pregunta que tiene un respaldo
mayoritario no obstante la pregunta será
diferente a la planteada por lópez
obrador la cual fue catalogada por la
corte como tendenciosa pues incluía los
nombres de enrique peña nieto- felipe
calderón vicente fox ernesto zedillo y
carlos salinas
calderón ha pedido anteriormente a lópez
obrador que si tiene pruebas contra el
las presentes sin necesidad de votación
mientras que vicente fox rechazó la
decisión en twitter
muy pero muy penoso en dónde estamos ya
dónde vamos nos están llevando al baile
despertemos mexicanos el presidente
busca realizar la consulta al mismo
tiempo que los históricos comicios del 6
de junio de 2021 en los que casi 100
millones de mexicanos elegirán miles de
cargos políticos y finalizamos en
ecuador porque se cumple el primer
aniversario del inicio de las protestas
tras la eliminación de subsidios a la
gasolina
las movilizaciones pusieron en jaque la
presidencia de lenin moreno luego de una
docena de días de presión social que
dieron como resultado el
restablecimiento de los subsidios al
combustible pero actualmente el país ha
sido escenario de nuevas movilizaciones
por recortes presupuestarios en
universidades despidos masivos y
reclamos electorales vamos a quitó con
nuestro corresponsal a gustavo ortega y
gustavo mientras los movimientos
sociales protestan el gobierno celebra
un pacto con el fondo monetario
internacional que fue lo que desencadenó
los recortes de hace un año
si es para ti tal y como lo has dicho
mientras ha pasado un año desde la
protesta de octubre de 2019 parece que
se estuvieran desarrollando las mismas
condiciones que motivaron la protesta de
hace un año es que las razones de aquel
entonces era la eliminación del decreto
883 la cual contemplaba la eliminación
de los subsidios por el cual un año más
tarde el ejecutivo nacional eliminó los
subsidios del combustible inclusive hace
pocos días también permite la
importación del combustible a empresas
privadas lo cual esto también según han
dicho los sectores de trabajadores
permitirá que ellos mismos establezcan
los precios también se eliminó el
subsidio y se estableció una banda de
precios al alza y a la baja también ha
sido uno de los cuestionamientos que
hacen los movimientos sociales lo cierto
es que se maneja también unas
movilizaciones de trabajadores docentes
educadores y médicos que han dicho
inclusive han declarado el mes de
octubre como el es de la resistencia y
la desocupación han planteado inclusive
varias actividades que se estarán
realizando durante el mes de octubre la
de ayer fue
de las primeras protestas en este
sentido de igual forma también han
habido protestas el sector médico han
habido protestas de los grupos en
feministas a propósito también del veto
presidencial al código orgánico de la
salud lo cierto es que está planteado
para este mes un plantón inmovilización
a la corte constitucional de igual forma
también se ha planteado una movilización
y planteo hacia el ministerio del
trabajo y también se ha convocado estado
diciendo menos interrumpirlo se nos
acaba el tiempo de noticiero gracias a
ustedes por estar con nosotros y sigan
en france 24
[Música]